paul auffray à quand les producteurs ne
seront plus la variable d'ajustement
dans ce prix alors dans la filière
porcine la la liberté d'entreprendre
dans notre adn en quelque sorte c'est ce
qui a conditionné le développement des
filières porcine depuis le depuis les
années 60 et donc forcément une filière
qui est en croissance à se construit un
peu de façon se construit de façon un
peu chaotique mais de façon régulière
malgré malgré ce retour de travers de
nos de nos organisations
mais la croissance gomme tout ça le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui depuis
depuis les années 80 en laye et puis les
années 90 on peint on est dans une forme
de saturation des marchés au niveau
européen et donc aujourd'hui sur notre
production le marché porcin fonction
beaucoup moins bien donc le principe de
l'offre et demande l'offre et la demande
est quelque chose sur lequel j'ai pas
grand chose à dire qu'au niveau européen
qu'au niveau mondial on puisse réguler à
partir de ce principe là me paraît
logique
je vois pas d'ailleurs comment on
pourrait faire autrement mais en tout
état de cause je sais pas parce que le
marché expriment une tendance de prix
que systématiquement le producteur doit
être scotché système en activement ce
prix mondial voilà d'ailleurs je ne vois
pas comment nous producteurs on puisse
continuer à travailler avec des coûts
français et charges française et en
produisant au co mondial juste pour
l'anecdote j'ai un de mes collègues qui
revient de chine après quinze jours de
travail pour faire du développement pour
ça là bas on parle beaucoup des
exportations de viande dans le monde
entier notamment en asie du sud-est pour
pouvoir exporter faut être soi disant
compétitif
en deux mots faut produire autour d'un
euro ce qu'on nous dit au quotidien
le problème c'est que le cours du porc
en chine et à 3 euros 3 euros
donc quand la viande porcine française
qui va en chine et vendus 1 euro va plus
un certain nombre de deux coups indexés
sur les coûts industriels en tout état
de cause on est trois fois moins cher
que les coûts de production chinois yeux
il ya comme un problème quelque part
donc là la valeur ajoutée elle passe
bien dans la poche de quelqu'un soit
celle industrielle ou du trader ou
forcément d'un acteur économique chinois
dont il ya vraiment un problème
donc aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui on
est aujourd'hui la variable d'ajustement
et puis ça va bien tout le monde ça va
bien aux industriels ça va bien surtout
aux distributeurs qui continuent de s'en
mettre plein les poches
j'irai au passage que moi j'ai comme
l'impression qu'en france le modèle
économique sur lequel on est basé pour
moi présente un problème majeur l'autre
jour vous allez rigoler j'ai été primés
dans les manifs agricole en bretagne
moi le responsable ricol j'étais pris
deux jours de suite entre saint brieuc
et rennes bloqué en ille et vilaine
bon j'arrête ou je vais pas gueuler
puisque j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont
encouragé mes collègues a bloqué les
routes et à mettre la pression
selon sur le gouvernement mais ce que
moi j'ai remarqué en étant un peu bloqué
pendant plusieurs heures
c'est que j'ai vu beaucoup de bâtiments
en construction beaucoup beaucoup dans
la région de rennes
le problème c'est que on construit
beaucoup de bâtiments mais pas une seule
usine on construit beaucoup de bâtiments
mais on construit que du commerce
moi ce que je crains c'est que demain la
france devienne un pays offshore comme
les comme la grande-bretagne adducteurs
voilà donc qu'on produise plus donc on
compte sur les produits que les pays
producteurs pour pouvoir générer de
l'activité en france à 7 heures par la
route de seconde
ça va tenir cinq ans dix ans mais quand
tous ces pays on connaître soit des
problèmes de croissance soit des
problèmes géopolitiques
on va se retrouver en panne sèche
forcément donc juste pour pour terminer
on a osé nous à la fédération nationale
porcine abordé le sujet de la
contractualisation
parce que à force de passer de 1 euro 1
euro 50 on sait plus gérer nous on sait
plus gérer
donc on s'est un petit peu appuyé sur ce
qui se fait dans le végétal a comme un
certain nombre d'outils de marché à
terme de couverture de de swap de
contrats tripartie pour qu'on a osé
parler de ça je me suis fait lyncher par
les responsables économiques de mon
secteur
je me suis fait lyncher on l'a fait on
l'a présenté lors de notre assemblée
générale
au mois de juin à vouloir mail le
problème c'est que c'est un dossier
technique compliqué où il faut à la fois
mettre autour de la table producteurs
industriels et distributeurs
et là il ya comme un problème il ya
comme un problème parce que forcément
nous éleveurs on s'invite un peu à la
table des négociations donc on est un
petit peu le vilain petit canard dans
cette affaire tout à fait donc on est là
dessus on est on est on est déçu mais
quand on en parle avec les distributeurs
autour de la table ils sont tous
d'accord quand il faut passer aux choses
sérieuses
y'a plus personne paul je pense paul en
conclusion sur cette contractualisation
faudra vraiment qu'on nous oblige à
mettre autour de la table les
producteurs les transformateurs et les
distributeurs et regarder comment on
peut avoir une juste répartition des
marges parce que c'est une porte de
sortie importante pour avoir une
rémunération des prix pour nous à vue